hey this is pressure Walker
the top auto insurance companies in
America all advertise savings
if you just switch to their insurance
policy you could save an average of
hundreds of dollars
but there's a logical Paradox with this
imagine you're at the top auto insurance
company
you can then switch to another company
for an average savings of 650 dollars
you might then switch to another company
for an average savings of 468 dollars
but why stop there you continue
switching for an average savings of five
hundred dollars and then you go back to
your original company and you can save
another average of 554 dollars
this is of course logically not possible
so how is it that every company can
offer savings when switching from one of
its competitors
so here's one reason why a company may
be selecting its customers carefully out
of all the customers they may be
researching that some group of them will
be a lower risk and it's an untapped
market so they can offer lower premiums
to customers they believe are lower risk
another reason is there may be a change
in coverage one company may be offering
you something the equivalent of fine
dining and the other will be offering
you a brown bag lunch
these are of course not the same types
of coverage
the lower price might come from lower
limits increased deductibles car changes
or other possible discounts
but a final issue is a selection
sampling bias let's take a look at one
of the claims of switching and saving an
average of 554 dollars if you read the
fine print it says that savings are
based on new customers who reported
savings by switching so they're only
taking a sample of customers who already
said they saved money to illustrate this
another way it's not a random sample
you have all these customers and maybe
some of them will switch to the new
company
they then ask the new customers which
ones of you saved money by switching to
this new policy some of them reported
they did save then they said all right
well how much money did you save they
said we saved an average of 554 dollars
so it's not truly a random sample of all
customers who switched it's a sample
bias
so experts recommend if you do want to
save money on your auto insurance here
are some of the steps you could take
talk to your current agent about
discounts get multiple quotes and
compare apples to apples also
investigate discounts like combining
with home insurance and always be aware
of phony numbers by the way did you know
100 of people like this video
based on average responsive people who
reported they like this video mind your
decisions information presented is for
education purposes only and design
substitute for proper financial advice
or common sense no one should take any
of this too seriously really
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you
[Music]